no i kind of agree but as always yeah  how much you weigh these  soft factors of course in these days  where champions have much more of a say  whom they would play against and when  well yeah  the numbers look pretty nice no we're a  champion for 27 years and so on oh  that's true oh yeah it's always thought  that it just depends what you're the top  four in chess is automatic i always  thought  just by strength i think it's just  magnus gary fisher carpro yeah and then  you start thinking about the rest yeah  yeah no i think that's that's a fair  take but  it's very difficult  once you start weighing in whatever i  think i sort of agree  magnus one  yeah  this was a remarkably smooth and  one-sided performance soon  also of course with hindsight  probably good choice because he knows  jan is incredibly well prepared but jan  hasn't played a thousand games in the